las vegas now host mercedes martinez is
right over there
joining us live from mix 941 this
morning mercedes i got to see you so
many times this week good morning
happy friday i know you got to be on
our show i get to be on your show it's
amazing we got to make this a trend
i'm just thinking this is where i agree
anyway guys i want to tell you what's
going on this morning a lot of
cool stuff first up trouble at
chick-fil-a
so the chicken chain says some items
will be unavailable because of an
industry-wide supply shortage
its sauces are on that list chick-fil-a
is limiting
customers to just one per entree two per
meal
and if you get the 30 piece nuggets
you're only gonna get three
sauces tragic i know from chick-fil-a
though
to a little eye candy let's talk about
soccer star david beckham he made
hawaiian shirts popular again
after he recently wore one in miami now
he was rocking it for saint laurent's
men's spring collection so
you know it is a fresh trend and now we
may be seeing even more aloha even if we
aren't in hawaii but
you're going to have to shell out a
pretty penny if you guys want this one
it's going to run you
790 dollars no john alex
you're going to be rocking a hawaiian
shirt anytime soon oh i'm not trying to
upstage david beckham no
yeah i mean i've i i've pulled i've
pulled off that david beckham look uh
poorly
uh so i've got a whole collection of the
david beckham hawaiian shirts for a lot
less than 790 dollars tell you that
oh my gosh okay i'll show up on monday
i'll show up on monday and one we'll see
how it goes
aloha monday oh boy can't wait to see
that oh we are
we are crossing our fingers for that i
cannot wait hey mercedes this search has
started for the next german baby already
but there's not a whole lot of time to
enter
yeah that is trending this morning the
last day to apply
is monday so if you have a little one
that is no older than 48 months old and
has an
infectious giggle your child could be
the next star
now the winner of the photo contest will
be featured
on gerber's social media accounts and
their marketing campaigns
they'll also receive 25 000
in cash now if you think your baby has
what it takes
all you have to do is upload your
favorite photos and video of your little
one
showing off their personality now by the
way john alex i know you don't have kids
but since we're talking about babies oh
boy
i wanted to see what a little john and a
little alex would look like so
we did a little magic uh i put john with
britney spears this is what a baby with
john and britney spears would look like
so adorable right yeah it's uh
yeah i'm sure something gerber is
tripping over themselves to try and get
their hands on that yeah what about alex
had a baby with brad pitt okay
um oh no it looks like uh
john from the toyota dealerships
yeah who is playing these mashups
together there's no way brad pitt's
could ever look
anything like that i don't know i think
they're
adorable yeah they are they're yeah
we'll go with that
thank you mercedes i hear we're out of
time unfortunately with you but thank
you we look forward to seeing your baby
mash up
i'm so sad i'll see you guys soon